it's great to be joined today by Erwin
Chemerinsky who's the Dean and
distinguished professor of law at UC
Berkeley School of Law also author of
the book We the People how the
Constitution is a progressive document
that can be adapted to the 21st century
this is so great to have you on I think
maybe we could start with the adaptation
part and then get to the progressive
part there is an argument from so called
constitutional original ist's who
believe that the correct interpretation
of the Constitution is very little
interpretation in other words that it
should be interpreted strictly literally
in the way that someone writing it in
the 18th century would have intended now
I know you don't agree with that but
let's lay out the case against
constitutional originalism to start with
the text of the Constitution is written
in very broad open-ended language what's
cruel and unusual punishment what's due
process of law what's equal protection
you're not going to find answers to that
in the text of the Constitution nor are
you're going to find it in the views of
those who wrote the Constitution in 1787
or wrote the Bill of Rights in 1791 that
assumes that they had a common
understanding in an agreement and the
reality is so many people were involved
in the process there were many different
views there was no single intent to be
found even if we could find it
constitutional rights are never
absolutely there's always a question of
balancing them against competing
interests finally the reality is it
would be absurd to be governed by the
views from those in 1787 or 1791 there
was a time of an agrarian slave Society
how can their views govern us in our
modern 21st century world give you
examples article 2 of the Constitution
refers the president and vice-president
with the pronoun he the framers the
Constitution clearly intended that the
President and Vice President would be
now does that mean that it's
unconstitutional like the woman has
vice-president until the Constitution is
amended the same Congress that voted to
ratify the 14th amendment also voted to
segregate the District of Columbia
Public Schools does that then mean that
Brown versus Board of Education was
wrongly decided any method of
interpretation that makes Brown wrongly
decided is obviously one that has to be
rejected can you let's go back to one
example you gave which is that of cruel
and unusual punishment a laypersons
interpretation of unusual would sound
contextual meaning unusual relative to
something some standards some prevalent
form of punishment that is what is
typically done is that lay understanding
of what unusual means relevant to our
understanding of constitutional
originalism or not or do we need to
apply a different definition of what
unusual would mean it's relevant but not
helpful it is the first case I ever
argued in the Supreme Court was Lockyer
versus Andrade my client Leandra Andrade
was sentenced to life in prison with no
possibility of parole for 50 years for
slaying $153 with the video tips from
Kmart stores in San Bernardino
California you see the sentence even
though he never committed a violent
crime
he received the sentence even though no
one in the history of the United States
had ever received a life sentence for
shoplifting until California's three
strikes law I would think that makes it
unusual I think it's cruel the Supreme
Court five-to-four
rejected that argument and upheld the
sentence the five conservative just then
being on the court come comprising the
majority I'm curious when it comes to
your view as to the double standard that
I see often may that exists with
so-called constitutional originalist
I'll give you one example and then I'll
let you tell me whether this examples
relevant or not or maybe there are
others if one believes in a strict
originalist interpretation of the
Constitution wouldn't that follow that
with as one example with the Second
Amendment by definition any lacks in
her predation in terms of what types of
firearms that exist today that didn't in
the 18th century would be interpret
interpretations beyond what was possible
when it was originally written is that a
fair critique or is there something
missing I think it's fair but I'd even
go to a prior question which was the
meaning of the Second Amendment it says
a well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free State the
right of the people to keep their arms
shall not be infringed it's clear what
the purpose was of the Second Amendment
protecting a right to have guns for the
purpose of militia service and yet it's
the conservative originalist justices
like Antonin Scalia who wanted to say oh
we'll ignore the first half of the
Second Amendment it's only the latter
language both right to keep the people
people to keep and bear arms that's
relevant but if we were gonna protect
arms does that then just mean the kind
of weapons that existed in 1791 when we
talk about freedom of the press does
that apply to the new media that's
developed since 1791 obviously for the
First Amendment of meaning it has to
apply to all of the media it wouldn't
make sense if there's a second right to
limit it to the weapons that existed in
1791 hmm I've pointed out that with with
many political arguments like for
example taxes or abortion there's a kind
of systemic messaging advantage that the
right has and what I mean by that is as
an example with taxes hey it's your
money you should get to keep it the
lower the taxes the better off we are
that's very concise pithy and appealing
in many ways the left on the other hand
is not advocating the opposite which is
the more taxes the better it's well we
need to find the right balance of what's
fair but what properly funds the
institutions of government that so we're
already kind of in a more complex
position when it comes to this issue of
constitutional originalism does the
right have the same advantage in the
sense that they say hey interpret it as
written period and the left's position
is not the opposite it's not whatever
you think it means is what it means it's
you're already
sort of at a structural disadvantage
well the right has a simplistic slogan
judges should apply the law not make the
law justices should be umpires we should
just follow the framers intent but of
course all of that is a big lie everyone
knows that justices and judges make the
law as well as applier Supreme Court
justices aren't umpires they're the ones
who make the rules not just the ones who
apply it there have to balance competing
interests all the time whereas baseball
umpires don't have to do that an
originalist conservatives don't follow
originalism when it doesn't serve their
purpose yet liberals don't have a pithy
easy way to describe their approach to
constitutional interpretation yes so so
what's the what's the answer in other
words how would you advise the left to
discuss this issue first show that the
right is an emperor with no clothes that
they're not doing what they say they're
doing and second that it would be very
undesirable to do what they say they're
doing what they would be saying is make
Brown versus Board of Education
unconstitutional they make it
unconstitutional if the woman is
president or vice president so I think
we need to show the emptiness of what
they've posed and ultimately throughout
American history very few Supreme Court
justice has been originalist where the
Supreme Court has done for over 200
years is look at the text look at the
intent look at tradition look at
precedent look at contemporary policy
needs and use those to decide the
meaning of the Constitution it's always
been that right the leftist has to
defend that's the way it should be so
let's talk about another aspect that
that the left I think should be
defending when it comes to the
Constitution which goes to the argument
you make in your book which is that the
Constitution is actually a progressive
document a quick glance at the
three-fifths clause some of the gender
related elements that you mentioned much
of what is in the Constitution interpret
literally doesn't sound super
progressive at least by 2019 standards
so how do
make the case that this is actually a
progressive document I think the
Constitution is a vessel and it can be
interpreted in a progressive way or can
be interpret in a conservative way I
think that the preamble of the
Constitution tells us the values that is
meant to achieve democratic governance
effective government justice Liberty and
I would add to that equality and I think
that what we should be doing is
interpreting the Constitution to further
those values and the book that you
mentioned that I've written instead of
We the People a progressive reading of
the Constitution for the 21st century
and I think there's a very important
distinction I do think that the
Constitution was meant to be a
progressive document but to me what's
key is how we interpret and read it now
when it comes to what can be done more
structurally today with regard to the
Supreme Court in particular and moving
in the direction of having a group of
justices that do interpret the
Constitution in a way that's consistent
with what you outline court packing is
increasingly mentioned the idea of
increasing the number of Supreme Court
justices what's your view on that tactic
and is it part of a broader strategy
that that could potentially backfire I
think it's something that progressives
should think about but I don't think
it's something progressives should talk
about until after the 2020 election hmm
in terms of thinking about it if
Democrats take the presidency in both
houses of Congress in 2020 I think they
need to think about whether they want to
increase the size of the Supreme Court
the seat that Justice Scalia had is
really a stolen seat it should have been
Merrick garland confirmed for that never
before in American history had the count
in the Senate said that they wouldn't
even hold hearings or a vote on a
candidate for the Supreme Court yes I
think that Democrats have a strong
argument saying given how Republicans
change the rules this is a stolen seat
we're going to increase the size the
size of the Supreme Court is set by
statute not by the Constitution 9 is
just historical at
and so there's nothing magical about it
the sort of reflexive response often is
okay well
Democrats could do that at their next
opportunity but then Republicans could
simply do it again ad infinitum is that
a problem it is and I think that's why
Democrats have to think twice about it
Democrats increased it to 11 if the
Republicans take the president's seat in
Congress in 2024 they could make it 13
and so on
is it worth opening that door what would
be the politics of it but I want to go
back to something I said I don't think
the progressives should be talking about
this right now yeah I think all it does
is encourage conservatives to come out
and vote so that they can have the court
exit polls in 2016 showed that the
number one reason that those who voted
for Trump get was the Supreme Court 54%
of Trump voters said that the Supreme
Court was the reason that they voted for
him I don't think we should fuel that
for 2020 yeah well so that gets us to
something I think was not talked about
enough in 2016 which is that there were
divisions on the Left about whether or
not the Supreme Court was so important
that it justified for example voting for
Hillary Clinton even though maybe your
choice from the Democratic primary was
not on that final ballot there was a
contingent on the left which I believe
did not take seriously enough the
importance of the Supreme Court case and
point were seeing that influence right
now how can we turn that around because
as you point out the exit polls
confirmed the people who voted for Trump
understood the importance of the Supreme
Court yesterday those who voted for
Trump that was the number one reason
they gave for those who vote for Hillary
Clinton was only number four in terms of
reasons why people voted for Hillary
Clinton
Republicans have done such a better job
of getting out the message that one of
the most long-lasting important things
the president does is put justice on the
Supreme Court and judges on the lower
federal courts Democrats and liberals
have not received the same extent once
and now the consequences of that with
Neal Gorsuch and Brett Kavanaugh they
could have been to progressives in those
seats why don't the progressives and
Democrats and liberals understand the
importance of that I don't know yeah I I
it's it's totally beyond me and one of
the mysteries that that I simply cannot
understand we've been speaking with
Erwin Chemerinsky who's Dean and
distinguished professor of law at UC
Berkeley School of Law we are linking in
the description for this video to his
latest book so great to speak to you
today I really appreciate you sir
anytime